ahora ya estamos listos para el problema
de tensión super picante aquí tenemos
una lata de chiles super picantes que
está colgando de estas dos cuerdas y
queremos saber cuál es la atención en
estas cuerdas este es un verdadero
problema de tensión y en un principio si
ustedes ven esto podrían asustarse un
poco y quizá querrán encontrar una nueva
estrategia para resolver esto pero esto
no es así no tienen que reinventar algo
nuevo cada vez que resuelvan un problema
complejo tenemos que hacer el mismo
procedimiento que hemos visto lo mismo
que hemos hecho para los problemas de
tensión sencillos porque nos van a
llevar a la respuesta correcta así que
no se desvíen de la estrategia que
tenemos lo primero que hacemos es
dibujar nuestro diagrama de fuerzas esto
siempre va a ser lo primero que hagamos
una de las fuerzas en esta lata de
chiles es la fuerza de gravedad que es
igual a la masa por la aceleración de la
gravedad m por g
y sabemos que esta lata tiene una masa
de 3 kilogramos 3 kilogramos por 10
metros por segundo al cuadrado que
sabemos que la aceleración de la
gravedad es 9.8 pero para facilitarnos
los cálculos lo redondeamos a 10 metros
por segundo al cuadrado así que tenemos
3 kilogramos por 10 metros por segundo
al cuadrado y esto nos da 30 newtons así
que la fuerza de gravedad hacia abajo es
de 30 minutos que otras fuerzas tenemos
tenemos aquí a tf1 y recuerden que la
tensión jamás empuja solo jala así que
nuestra cuerda nos va a jalar la lata
hacia acá con una tensión de 1 aquí
dibujamos a tf1
y ahora te dos tenemos que apuntar hacia
este otro lado nuevamente t2 va a jalar
una atención jamás para empujar
solamente va a jalar mi intención 2 va
hacia acá y este es nuestro diagrama de
fuerzas no hay más fuerzas involucradas
aquí no dibujo una fuerza normal porque
esta lata no está en contacto con otra
superficie así que no tenemos fuerza
normal tenemos estas dos tensiones y la
fuerza de gravedad y ahora hacemos lo de
siempre vamos a usar nuestra segunda ley
de newton en una dirección o en la otra
vamos a hacerlo la aceleración es igual
a la fuerza neta entre la masa qué
dirección es la que vamos a elegir bueno
es difícil de decidir tenemos fuerzas
verticales y tenemos fuerzas
horizontales y sólo hay dos direcciones
para elegir la equis olaya vamos a
elegir la dirección vertical aunque
realmente no importa mucho pero elegimos
esta dirección porque ya conocemos una
de las
verticales conocemos la fuerza de
gravedad que es de 30 minutos y aquí la
estrategia es elegir aquella dirección
en donde tenemos alguna fuerza que ya
conocemos vamos a hacerlo aquí digamos
que nuestra aceleración vertical es
igual a la fuerza neta vertical entre la
masa tenemos aquí nuestra lata que no se
está moviendo es decir no tiene
aceleración alguna no está en un
elevador en donde esté cambiando de
posición y tampoco se encuentra en un
cohete se encuentra solamente aquí
colgada por estas dos cuerdas por lo que
nuestra aceleración va a ser cero esto
va a ser igual a la fuerza neta en la
dirección vertical cuáles son estas
fuerzas verticales bueno una ya vimos
que son los 30 newtons de la fuerza de
gravedad esto apunta hacia abajo y vamos
a suponer que todo lo que apunta hacia
arriba es positivo y lo que apunta hacia
abajo es negativo por lo que aquí pondré
menos 30 newtons
pude haber escrito menos m por g pero ya
tenemos el valor de esto así que lo
ponemos directamente aquí ahora tenemos
t1 y t2 ambas apuntan hacia arriba pero
no completamente apuntan hacia arriba
solamente en parte una parte de tf1
apunta a la derecha y otra apunta hacia
arriba y solamente este componente
vertical que le llamamos t 1 y es el que
vamos a incluir en estos cálculos ya que
aquí sólo consideramos las fuerzas que
actúan verticalmente y la razón es
porque únicamente las fuerzas que actúan
verticalmente me afectan la aceleración
vertical está t1 y apunta hacia arriba
por lo que es positiva
aquí la pongo más de 1 y de forma
similar estate 2 no apunta completamente
hacia arriba solo una parte de ella
apunta hacia arriba y este 2 que también
apunta hacia arriba por lo que es
positiva y aquí lo escribo como más
de 2 y estas son todas nuestras fuerzas
noten que no podemos poner la cantidad
completa de estas dos tensiones t1 y t2
en esta fórmula ya que sólo una parte de
ellas es la que apunta hacia arriba
ahora dividimos todo esto entre la masa
que es de 3 kilogramos pero vamos a
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por tres kilogramos me queda que 0 es
igual a todo esto de aquí arriba lo voy
a copiar y pegar ahora no tenemos nada
aquí abajo y qué vamos a hacer ahora que
llegamos a este punto quizás piensen que
ya nos atoramos y no sabemos qué más
hacer pues tenemos dos elementos
desconocidos y no puedo despejar ninguna
de ellas porque no las conozco sé que
ambas tienen que ser igual a 30 por lo
que puedo poner aquí 30 de este otro
lado y me doy cuenta que estos dos
componentes verticales de las tensiones
al agregar se me igualan o me equilibran
la fuerza de gravedad lo que tiene
sentido porque me balancean la dirección
hacia abajo porque
balancean lo que va hacia abajo sin
embargo no conozco ninguno de estos dos
componentes y lo que vamos a hacer cada
que nos encontremos como que atorados
porque desconocemos estas variables
vamos a hacer el cálculo de la segunda
ley de newton pero en la otra dirección
ahora vamos a tener a en la dirección
horizontal es igual a la fuerza neta en
la dirección horizontal en x entre la
masa nuevamente mi aceleración va a ser
cero ya que esta lata de chiles se
encuentra quieta no es que todo esto se
esté desplazando horizontalmente en un
caso así si tendríamos cierta
aceleración horizontal pero este no es
el caso y aunque lo fuera no hay
problema simplemente ponemos aquí la
aceleración que tenga pero como aquí
nuestra lata está quieta nuestra
aceleración va a ser cero y ahora
ponemos las fuerzas en la dirección
horizontal
aquí tenemos t 1 x
parte de mi tensión uno apunta hacia la
derecha y de igual manera parte de mi
tensión 2 apunta en la dirección
horizontal en este caso hacia la
izquierda este este 2x la componente
horizontal de t 2 apunta hacia la
izquierda y la componente horizontal
desde 1 apunta a la derecha tenemos que
decidir qué signo le vamos a dar a cada
dirección y voy a establecer que de 1 x
como apunta hacia la derecha va a ser
positivo todo lo que apunte a la derecha
lo voy a considerar positivo y todo lo
que apunte a la izquierda lo voy a
considerar negativo en esta es una
convención típica y la vamos a usar de 2
x apunta hacia la izquierda por lo que
va a ser una contribución negativa tengo
menos de 2 en la dirección x lo
dividimos entre la masa que es de 3
kilogramos y nuevamente multiplicamos a
ambos lados por 3 kilogramos y me queda
que 0 es igual a t 1 x menos de 2x
veamos esto y lo ponemos aquí abajo y
quizás ustedes se preocupen de que
tampoco pueden resolver esto pues no
conocen ninguna de estas dos variables
puedo despejar ate 1x pero que me queda
si sumo de 2x en ambos lados me va a
quedar que t 1 de la dirección x va a
ser igual a todos en la dirección x y
esto tiene sentido ya que ambas fuerzas
tienen que tener la misma magnitud para
equilibrarse y así no tener ninguna
aceleración en la dirección horizontal y
aquí no he hecho el dibujo a escala
estos dos vectores deberían ser iguales
porque tienen la misma magnitud pero
bueno esta ecuación no la puedo resolver
que es para mi dirección horizontal y
tampoco puedo resolver esta otra fórmula
que es para mi dirección vertical cuando
esto suceda que tengan dos ecuaciones y
no puedan resolver ambas porque tienen
muchas incógnitas van a tener que
incluir una de las fórmulas dentro de la
otra pero tampoco puedo hacer eso aquí
tengo
cuatro variables diferentes de 1 x de 2
x t1 y t2 tengo cuatro incógnitas y dos
ecuaciones lo que voy a tener que hacer
acá que es algo que a muchas personas no
les gusta hacer porque pues es un
poquito más complicado es dejar todas
estas variables en términos de t1 y t2
para que podamos sustituir ahora si
nuestras variables
voy a poner aquí t 1 d en términos de t
1 con algún seno de ángulo o coseno de
ángulo y también voy a tener que poner t
2 en términos de t 2 x algún seno o
coseno de ángulo lo mismo haré para t 1
x y para t 2x de manera que nuestras
únicas incógnitas sean t1 y t2
así finalmente podremos encontrar los
valores si esto los confunde lo que voy
a hacer es dejar de 1 y de 1 x en
términos de t 1 para esto necesito
conocer estos ángulos de aquí vamos a
hacerlo si aquí tengo un ángulo de 30
grados aquí abajo también voy a tener un
ángulo de 30 grados ya que son ángulos
alternos internos y si no me creen
imagínense que aquí tenemos un triángulo
este es un ángulo rectángulo el
triángulo va de aquí acá y hasta acá si
esto es 30 estos 90 esto va a tener que
ser de 60 grados ya que la suma de los
ángulos internos debe ser igual a 180
grados y si este es un ángulo recto y
este pedazo es de 60 grados este otro
ángulo tendrá que ser de 30 grados
de forma similar ahora tenemos este otro
triángulo aquí tengo 60 grados
esos son 90 grados por lo que aquí debe
de tener un ángulo de 30 grados y si ese
70 grados el ángulo de aquí abajo tendrá
que ser igual a 60 para que sumen entre
los dos los 90 grados nuevamente son
ángulos internos alternos este ángulo de
aquí es de 60 grados este de aquí es de
30 y ahora podemos calcular cuáles son
estos componentes en términos de los
vectores completos ya que los
encontramos los vamos a sustituir en
estas fórmulas y ahora sí podremos
despejar así que tf1 lleva a ser igual
nos damos cuenta que este es el lado
opuesto del ángulo por lo que este
componente va a ser todo t 1 x el seno
de 30 porque es el lado opuesto
y si no les queda claro vamos a hacerlo
más explícito aquí seno de 30 es igual
al lado opuesto entre la hipotenusa
en este caso el lado opuesto este 1 y
entre todo t 1 y esto es igual al seno
de 30
despejamos de 1 y nos queda que si
multiplicamos ambos lados porque uno de
uno lleva a ser igual a de uno por seno
de 30 y es lo que escribí aquí que de
hecho me faltó el 1 t1 y es igual a 1
seno de 30 y si hacemos lo mismo con el
coseno de 30 nos quedará que esté 1x es
igual a t 1 por el coseno de 30 usamos
el mismo proceso y de manera similar
aquí de 2x va a ser igual a todos por el
coseno de 60
ya que este es el lado adyacente y t2
lleva a ser igual a de 2 por el seno de
60 grados si esto los confunde revisen
esta parte de aquí arriba donde está la
definición del seno y recuerda la
definición del cose lo aquí se encuentra
el lado opuesto
esta es la hipotenusa despejamos nuestra
expresión y obtenemos estos resultados
si no me creen pueden hacer los cálculos
y despejes ustedes mismos pero estos son
los valores de nuestros componentes en
términos de t 2 y tf1 y de los ángulos
que les corresponden por que hicimos
esto lo hicimos para poder sustituir
esto en esta fórmula y dejar todo en
términos de t1 y t2 de esta manera sólo
tendremos dos variables de 1 y lo
sustituyó por esto de aquí de 1 por seno
de 30
y ahora tomo t2 y lo sustituyó aquí que
es igual a todos por el seno de 60 lo
sustituyó en esta expresión y me va a
quedar 0 igual
menos 30 minutos más de uno es de uno
por el seno de 30 grados y podemos
simplificar esto sabemos que el seno de
30 es un medio por lo que aquí pongo t 1
entre 2 y t2 es de 2 por el seno de 60
grados el seno de 60 grados es raíz de 3
entre 2 por lo que aquí pongo de 2 raíz
de 3 entre 2 escribimos de 2 entre 2 por
raíz de 3
y pueden decirme que pues la verdad no
ha mejorado mucho sigue siendo bastante
complicado pero noten que ya estas dos
ecuaciones están en términos de t1 y t2
lo mismo voy a hacer aquí voy a poner
estos dos en términos de t1 y t2 de 1 x
es igual a t 1 por el coseno de 30
grados y coseno de 30 grados es raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 2 esto es de 1 entre
2 por raíz cuadrada de 3
y esto debe ser igual a t 2 x que es de
2 coseno de 60
el coseno de 60 es un medio por lo que
este 2 entre 2
aquí solamente sustituir lo que estos
componentes son en términos la magnitud
total y el ángulo en términos de la
magnitud total y el ángulo y ahora tengo
una ecuación en términos de t1 y t2 y
otra ecuación también en términos de t1
y t2 cuando tenemos dos ecuaciones con
dos incógnitas tenemos que despejar una
de las incógnitas y sustituirla en la
otra ecuación y de esta manera tendremos
una ecuación con una incógnita y
tratamos de hacer bien las operaciones
matemáticas y resolveremos el problema
puede despejar primero esta que se me
hace la más fácil
voy a despejar t 2 multiplicó a ambos
lados de la igualdad por 2 y me queda
que t 2 es igual a t 1 x raíz cuadrada
de 3 estos dos de abajo se cancelaron
con la multiplicación del 2 en ambos
lados
t 2 es igual a t 1 por raíz cuadrada de
3 lo que es muy bueno porque ahora lo
voy a sustituir en esta otra fórmula y
ahora tendré una ecuación con una sola
incógnita ya que solo nos quedaremos con
t 1 vamos a deshacernos de este
componente negativo aquí vamos a sumar
ambos lados de la igualdad con 30
newtons vamos a ponerlo por aquí abajo y
nos queda que 30 positivo es igual a tf1
entre 2 más de 2 que es igual a de 1 por
raíz cuadrada de 3 ponemos t 1 por raíz
cuadrada de 3 x la otra raíz de 3 que
tengo aquí
recordemos que t2 solito era t 1 por
raíz de 3 tomamos esto y lo sustituimos
aquí y lo multiplicó por raíz de 3 y
todo lo dividimos entre 2
a raíz de 3 x raíz de 3 nos queda que es
3 tenemos de 1 por tres medios más de 1
entre 2 es igual a 30 30 es igual a de 1
ya casi terminamos no se preocupen de 1
entre 2 más
uno por tres entre dos y tres de uno
entre dos y esto es igual de uno entre
dos más tres de uno entre dos es igual a
4 t1 entre dos y nos quedan 2 t1
y nos queda algo muy bonito esto es
igual a 2 t1 y ahora podemos despejar t
1 de 1 es simplemente 30 dividido entre
2 dividimos ambos lados entre 2 y este
lado izquierdo me queda 30 entre 2 aquí
pongo las unidades todos estos son
newtons lo que nos da 15 newtons
vaya terminamos
t 1 es igual a 15 minutos ya tenemos el
valor de una de las tensiones como
obtengo la otra tensión
pues nos regresamos al principio no no
es cierto eso sería terrible lo que
hacemos es tomamos este uno lo que
hacemos es que tomamos nuestra t1 y la
sustituimos aquí t 2 es igual a t 1 x
raíz de tres así que multiplicó raíz de
tres por mi t 1 y t 1 es 15 minutos por
lo que este 2 es igual a 15 por raíz de
3 newtons
ya que obtenemos una de nuestras fuerzas
obtener la otra es muy sencillo esto es
de 2
en caso de que se me hayan perdido con
tanta operación lo que debe de entender
es que dibujamos primero nuestro
diagrama de fuerzas después usamos
nuestra segunda ley de newton en la
dirección vertical no pudimos resolverla
porque teníamos dos incógnitas usamos la
segunda ley de newton pero en la
dirección horizontal y tampoco pudimos
resolverlo porque teníamos otras dos
incógnitas por lo que pusimos todas
nuestras cuatro incógnitas en términos
de solo dos incógnitas de 120 dos vimos
como estos componentes dependían de los
vectores completos
sustituimos esas expresiones en cada una
de las incógnitas de nuestras fórmulas y
una vez hecho esto nos quedamos con dos
ecuaciones y dos incógnitas t1t2 t1 y t2
despejamos una de estas ecuaciones
dejamos de dos en términos de t 1
sustituimos de 2 en la otra fórmula y
nos quedamos con una ecuación y una
incógnita despejamos nuestra incógnita
obtuvimos esto que es nuestra
y ya que obtuvimos esta variable la
sustituimos en esta otra ecuación en
donde despejamos t 2 y obtuvimos nuestra
segunda tensión así que aunque parezca
que la segunda ley de newton no nos da
el resultado que queremos si perseveran
en sus cálculos si tienen confianza en
lo que conocen van a lograr resolver el
problema